nuestro speaker señor
vicepresidenta
primera dama segundo caballero es un
placer verlos
miembros del congreso
[Aplausos]
Por cierto pues es voy a necesitar una
orden ella debería poder ir al juego la
otra semana yo debo quedarme en casa hay
que hacer que funcione miembros del
gabinete de líderes de nuestro ejército
jefe de Justicia pues es asociados
jueces retirados Corte Suprema Y ustedes
compañeros estadounidenses miren empiezo
hoy dando la bienvenida al congreso al
nuevo líder de la casa de la cámara
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no quiero arruinar su reputación pero
tengo muchas ganas de trabajar con usted
y Quiero felicitar al nuevo líder de la
cámara
el primer líder de La minoría Ah por
estadounidenses el primer líder de esta
minoría en la cámara también
bueno Me alegra mucho haber hecho
campaña por él felicitaciones al líder
qué más ha servido la historia del
senado de Estados Unidos
[Aplausos]
felicitaciones también
bueno es otro periodo como líder de
Almería en el senado miren creo
yo creo que en esta ocasión has tenido
una mayoría superior finalmente fuiste
un líder de la mayoría pues un poquito
más grande cierto voy a decir algo
quiero darle un reconocimiento especial
para que que creo que va a ser
considerado como el mayor líder de la
cámara de representantes Nancy pelosi
Fox damas y caballeros la historia de
Estados Unidos es una historia de
Progreso y de resiliencia siempre hemos
dado el paso hacia adelante nunca nos
hemos rendido es una historia única
entre todas las naciones somos el único
país que ha emergido de cualquier crisis
a la que ha ingresado cada vez más
fuerte mucho más fuerte que como estaba
antes miren damas y caballeros eso es lo
que vamos a hacer de nuevo hace dos años
la economía estaba Sufriendo y yo estoy
aquí de frente ustedes
y con el apoyo de mucha gente en esta
habitación hemos creado 12 millones de
trabajos son la mayor cantidad de
trabajos que se ha creado en un periodo
presidencial para el pueblo
estadounidense
hace dos años
el covid había cerrado nuestros negocios
nuestras escuelas
se Nos quitó tanto y hoy el covid ya no
controla nuestras vidas hace dos años la
democracia enfrentaba la peor amenaza
desde la guerra civil y hoy
nuestra democracia sigue sin ser rota
Mientras nos reunimos esta noche
escribimos un nuevo capítulo en la gran
historia estadounidense una historia de
Progreso y de resiliencia cuando líderes
mundiales me piden que Define Estados
Unidos y lo hacen créanlo No yo lo
defino una sola palabra hablo en serio
posibilidades no pensamos que nada Está
más allá nuestras capacidades todo es
una posibilidad
se nos dice frecuentemente que los
demócratas y los republicanos no pueden
trabajar juntos pero en los últimos dos
años hemos probado a la gente que lo
niega que es posible Sí hay muchos
desacuerdos Y sí Hay momentos en los que
los demócratas no se llevan bien pero
una y otra vez los demócratas del
republicanos se han reunido se reunieron
para defender a una Europa y hacerla más
segura se reunieron para aprobar una
acta infraestructura única generacional
que conecta nuestro pueblo nos reunimos
para probar la ley más significa para
ayudar a exponer Los Pozos tóxicos
[Aplausos]
eso es muy importante
de hecho
firme más de 300 piezas legislativas
bipartidistas desde que me he convertido
presidente desde aprobar la ley de
consumo un acta de reforma electoral la
protección al matrimonio igualitario y
Bueno les puedo decir que si hemos
trabajado juntos en el congreso anterior
no hay ninguna razón por la cual no
podamos hacerlo en este congreso decir
cosas importantes
miren damas y caballeros
[Aplausos]
todos están tan informados como yo pero
esa bondad dando un mensaje importante
la gente luchar por la pelea ejercer el
poder por el poder el conflicto por el
conflicto no nos lleva a ningún lado esa
siempre ha sido mi visión del país y
creo que es la misma de ustedes
restaurar el alma de sanación
reconstruir la columna vertebral de
Estados Unidos de la clase media
estadounidense unir al país
nos han enviado a terminar un trabajo
por décadas la clase media ha sido
apartada
no solamente una administración sino por
mucho tiempo muchos buenos trabajos de
manufactura han ido a otros países han
cerrado dos fábricas
ciudades y pueblos que estaban
progresando se han convertido en sombra
de lo que solían ser en el camino hemos
perdido algo más el orgullo
nuestro sentido de autoestima y yo
aspira la presidencia para cambiar
fundamentalmente las cosas para
asegurarme que nuestra economía funcione
para todos para que todos podamos sentir
ese orgullo en lo que hacemos construir
una economía desde el fondo hasta arriba
No desde arriba hacia abajo porque
cuando la clase media le va bien unos
pobres los pobres tienen Camino hacia el
acento la clase Rica le va bien y a
todos nos va bien
[Aplausos]
y yo sé que muchos de ustedes se burlan
de mí por hablar de mi papá pero él me
decía yo vi los trabajos valen más que
un cheque el de verdad lo decía se trata
de más de un cheque se trata de la
dignidad se trata del respeto se trata
de ser capaz de ver al niño a los ojos y
decirle cariño Todo va a estar bien
estoy hablando en serio y hablar en
serio damas y caballeros miremos los
resultados y no hemos terminado todavía
en lo absoluto pero la tasa de desempleo
es de tres punto cuatro por ciento es el
punto más bajo en 15 años
[Aplausos]
un récord anual
un récord anual de desempleo
[Aplausos]
para los trabajadores afro e hispanos ya
hemos creado con ayuda de ustedes
800.000 trabajos bien pagos en
manufactura es el crecimiento más rápido
en 40 años
[Aplausos]
se ha dicho que Estados Unidos no puede
liderar el mundo de la manufactura yo no
sé dónde ha sido escrito eso por muchas
décadas hemos creado proyectos hemos
exportado trabajos ahora Gracias a todo
lo que ustedes han hecho estamos
exportando productos y creando trabajos
estadounidenses
damas y caballeros
[Aplausos]
la inflación
la inflación ha sido un problema global
porque la pandemia irrumpió en nuestras
cadenas de suministro de suministro y la
guerra injusta y brutal de Putin en
Ucrania y rompió los acabó con los
suministros de energía y de alimentos
bloqueando todo el grano de Ucrania pero
estamos en una mejor posición que
cualquier otro país en la tierra tenemos
mucho más que hacer aquí en casa la
inflación está reduciéndose aquí en casa
los precios de la gasolina están
disminuyéndose un dólar y medio desde su
pico los precios alimenticios están
bajando no tan rápido pero están bajando
la inflación está creciendo está bajando
cada mes desde los últimos seis meses
mientras Los sueldos han aumentado
adicionalmente en los últimos dos años
un récord 10 millones de estadounidenses
aplicaron para empezar nuevos negocios
10 millones Por cierto
[Aplausos]
cada vez
cada vez que alguien empieza un pequeño
negocio es un acto de Esperanza
señora vicepresidente quiero agradecerle
a usted Por liderar ese esfuerzo para
asegurarse que los pequeños negocios
tengan acceso al capital
y que haya leyes históricas que estén
permitiendo
el año pasado les prometió les compartí
una historia de un genio estadounidense
hablando de sus posibilidades de la
posibilidad de hacer semiconductores los
chips los microscópicos del tamaño de
una huella presente en celulares
automóviles en muchas cosas estos chips
fueron inventados en Estados Unidos
aseguremos esto fueron inventados en
Estados Unidos
solíamos hacer 40% de los chips del
mundo en las últimas décadas perdimos
nuestra ventaja y solamente producimos
un 10%
todos vimos que pasó durante la pandemia
cuando las fábricas de chips fueron
clausuradas en otros países los autos de
hoy necesitan tres mil chips cada uno
pero los automóviles estadounidenses las
fábricas automotrices no pueden hacer
suficientes aquí porque no había chips
tocó echar gente todo desde celulares
hasta refrigeradores no pudimos
producirlo y no podemos dejar que eso
pase de nuevo por eso es que nos
reunimos para aprobar la acta de chips
el acta bipartidista el chips y de
ciencia
[Aplausos]
caballeros
sé que se me ha criticado por decir eso
pero no quiero cambiar ni voy a cambiar
mi perspectiva nos vamos a asegurar de
que la cadena de suministro para Estados
Unidos empiece en Estados Unidos la
cadena de suministros empieza en Estados
Unidos
ya hemos creado
[Aplausos]
800 mil nuevos trabajos en manufactura
sin esta ley antes de esta ley antes de
que esta ley empezar a actuar con esta
nueva ley vamos a crear cientos de miles
de trabajos nuevos en todo el país y
estoy hablando de todo el país No
solamente en la costa sino la mitad del
país también eso va a provenir de
compañías que han enunciado más de 300
mil millones de dólares en inversión en
la manufactura estadounidense en los
próximos años
más allá de Columbus Ohio Intel va a
construir una cadena
literalmente un campo de sueños y va a
crear Diez mil trabajos esa sola
inversión 7000 trabajos de construcción
tres mil trabajos en esas fábricas una
vez estén terminadas se les va a llevar
fábricas de verdad trabajos que pagan un
promedio de 130 mil dólares al año
muchos no requieren un cargo un grado
universitario
[Aplausos]
los trabajos
ya que trabajamos juntos estos trabajos
significan que la gente no va a tener
que abandonar su hogar para conseguir
una oportunidad y esto Apenas está
empezando piensen en esto los nuevos
hogares los nuevos negocios los negocios
de talla media se va a necesitar tanto
para respaldar
a esos tres mil trabajos permanentes en
las fábricas que se van a construir
hablen con los alcaldes y los
gobernadores demócratas y republicanos
ellos les dirán qué es lo que significa
para sus comunidades estamos viendo
estos campos de sueños que transforman
el corazón de nuestra tierra pero para
mantener una economía fuerte en el mundo
necesitamos la mejor infraestructura del
mundo
damas y caballeros
[Aplausos]
como todos ustedes saben
solíamos ser el número uno en el mundo
en temas de infraestructura pasamos al
número 13 los Estados Unidos de América
el puesto 13 en el mundo en
infraestructura moderna ahora vamos a
volver estamos volviendo porque nos
reunimos y aprobamos el acto
bipartidista de infraestructura la mayor
inversión en infraestructura desde el
presidente
su sistema Interestatal de autopistas
damas y caballeros
ya hemos patrocinado 20.000 proyectos
incluyendo grandes aeropuertos desde
Boston Atlanta Portland proyectos que
van a poner a miles de personas a
trabajar estamos con autopistas puentes
vías férrea túneles puertos aeropuertos
agua limpia internet de alta velocidad
en todo estadounidense
urbano rural tribal personas estamos en
Caballeros estamos empezando apenas
estamos empezando
[Aplausos]
y estoy hablando en serio
quiero agradecerle a mis amigos
republicanos que votaron por el muro por
esta ley a los que votaron en contra de
esta ley también
todavía se me pregunta todavía se me
pide que patrocine estos proyectos en
los distritos pero no se preocupen
prometí ser presidente para todos los
estadounidenses Y patrocinaremos estos
proyectos y los quiero ver en la
inauguración
miren
esta ley
esta ley unirá a todo Estados Unidos
proyectos como los puentes en Kentucky
sobre el río Ohio construidos hace 60
años que necesitan una gran reparación
una de las vías más congestionadas que
llevan alrededor de dos mil millones de
dólares de mercancía cada día estamos y
caballeros estoy hablando he hablado de
arreglarla por décadas finalmente vamos
a lograrlo fui allá el mes pasado con
demócratas y republicanos de ambos
estados para entregar este compromiso de
1600 millones de dólares para este
proyecto
[Aplausos]
mientras estaba ahí
Conocí una joven chica llamada Sara que
está por aquí no sé dónde está bueno y
la vemos Sara Sara Cómo estás
durante 30 años
supe ella me dijo que había sido una
gran una integrante de
el sindicato local
conocido como los Cowboys en el cielo
Los Vaqueros del cielo
fueron los que construyeron
los edificios de Cincinnati Sara dice
que no puede esperar a construir este
puente sobre el río es la verdad es que
es un gran orgullo y estamos respaldando
ese orgullo miren también vamos a
reemplazar estos estas tuberías que
están envenenando a miles de hogares en
Estados Unidos 400.000 escuelas y
centros de Cuidado infantil cada niño en
Estados Unidos cada niño en Estados
Unidos puede beber una buena agua en vez
de sufrir un daño permanente en su
cerebro miren
nos estamos asegurando
de que cada comunidad cada comunidad en
Estados Unidos tenga acceso a un
internet de alta velocidad ningún padre
tenía que pasar por el parqueadero de
McDonald's para ayudar a su hijo a hacer
la tarea en internet
miles de personas hacen eso en todo el
país cuando ejecutamos estos proyectos
de nuevo recibo críticas pero no me
disculpen lo absoluto vamos a empezar a
comprar productos estadounidenses
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Y eso es completamente consistente con
las leyes de comercio internacional
comprar estadounidense Estados Unidos ha
perdido
las últimas administraciones de Estados
Unidos demócratas y republicanas han
tratado de luchar contra estas
restricciones y ya no más hoy estoy
anunciando que se necesita que todos los
materiales de construcción utilizados en
instituciones Federal en infraestructura
Federal que sean hechos en Estados
Unidos
[Aplausos]
hechos en Estados Unidos
estoy hablando en serio
madera vidrio Drywall cables voy a ver
los puentes las carreteras todo hecho
con materiales estadounidenses damas y
caballeros mi plan se trata de invertir
en lugares en personas que han sido
olvidadas
muchos de ustedes están escuchándome hoy
y yo sé que ustedes lo están sintiendo
muchos de ustedes sintieron como si
hubieran simplemente sido olvidados
creo que ha sido la situación de los
últimos las últimas cuatro décadas mucha
gente ha sido dejada atrás tratada como
si fuese invisible de pronto puede hacer
usted que está viendo desde casa
recuerde los trabajos que se fueron de
su pueblo ustedes se acuerdan cierto la
gente en casa se acuerda se acuerdan
cuando cierto camino existía para que
los niños salieran adelante sin
necesitar irse de su pueblo por eso
porque entiendo eso
estamos construyendo una economía donde
nadie quede atrás los trabajos se Están
volviendo el orgullo está regresando
porque las elecciones que hemos tomado
en los últimos años
han sido las correctas Miren esta es mi
perspectiva
de el trabajo obrero que reconstruye
Estados Unidos que realmente puede
marcar la diferencia en casa
muchos de ustedes por ejemplo
están en cama Como mi papá mirando el
techo y preguntándose que pasaría si sus
parejas resultan con cáncer o sus hijos
resultan gravemente enfermos o si algo
le pasa a ustedes
tendrían dinero para pagar con esas
cuentas o tendrían que vender la casa
tratar de buscar una segunda hipoteca Yo
entiendo eso Yo entiendo esto
con la el acta de reducción de la
inflación que ya se firmó como ley vamos
a enfrentar a los intereses poderosos
para tratar de disminuir el costo de la
salud para que ustedes puedan dormir
mejor para que tenga más seguridad miren
pagamos más por drogas de prescripción
que cualquier otra nación del mundo y lo
voy a decir de nuevo pagamos más por
medicinas de prescripción que cualquier
gran nación en la tierra Por ejemplo
uno de diez estadounidenses tiene
diabetes muchos de ustedes en esta
cámara lo tienen muchos en la audiencia
también pero cada día millones necesitan
insulina para esa diabetes literalmente
para mantenerse con vida esto ha sido
así por 200 años la persona que le
inventó ni siquiera lo patentó porque
quería que estuviera dispuesto
disponible para todos el costo para las
compañías médicas es como de unos 10
dólares
el empaque lo sube A 13 dólares pero las
grandes farmacéuticas están cobrando
cientos de dólares
al mes tratando de hacer grandes
ganancias y eso ya no va a ser así ya no
puede ser así
ya no puede ser así
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Hay tantas cosas que hemos hecho que
apenas ahora se están pudiendo ver
dijimos que lo íbamos a hacer dijimos
que íbamos a probar la ley para hacerlo
pero la gente no lo sabía porque la ley
no había tenido efecto hasta en primero
de enero este año
mantuvimos el costo de la insulina en 35
dólares al mes para las personas en el
Medicare
las personas están aprendiendo está
Sabiendo esto ahora y creo que ustedes
están recibiendo las llamadas que yo
estoy recibiendo miren millones de
estadounidenses
no están en mediqueros incluyendo
200.000 jóvenes con diabetes tipo 1 que
necesitan esta insulina para mantenerse
con vida terminemos el trabajo en esta
ocasión
va mantengamos el precio de la insulina
para todos en 35 dólares
[Aplausos]
damas y caballeros
las grandes farmacéuticas van a
funcionar bastante bien estoy seguro y
se los prometo les va a seguir yendo
bien
esta ley también le pone tope y
solamente entrará en efecto en 2025
le pondrá a tope
los adultos mayores que están presentes
máximo de
200 sin importar lo Mac lo mucho que
cuesta la droga va a haber un tope para
estas medicinas Miren la mayoría de
ustedes muchos de mi familia tienen
cáncer
y las medicinas pueden pasar de 10 11
12.000 15.000 dólares para el cáncer
particularmente los precios aumentan
mucho más rápido que la inflación
y las compañías farmacéuticas van a
tener que pagarle a medicar la
diferencia finalmente
le estamos dando América era el poder de
negociar Los costos de la medicina y
vamos a reducir
el costo de prescripciones no solamente
los adultos mayores
eso también disminuye el déficit Federal
por millones de dólares por cientos de
millones de dólares porque estas
medicinas de prescripción
son compras por parte del Medicare
para mantener su compromiso con los
adultos mayores y miren en vez de eso en
vez de pagar
15 dólares vamos a pagar cuatro o cinco
a ver un gran ahorro para el Gobierno
Federal por qué abrimos de querer eso
algunos se preguntan algunos miembros
están amenazando y sé que esto no es una
posición oficial del partido Y no quiero
exagerarlo pero de repente hay una
cierta repelencia la acta de reducción
de la inflación y está bien está bien es
justo
como decía mi entrenador de fútbol hay
mucha gente con suerte en su último año
Aquí no hay ningún error y si se intenta
aumentar el costo de las medicinas de
prescripción yo lo voy a vetar
[Aplausos]
miren
me complace decir que más
estadounidenses tienen seguro ahora que
nunca antes en la historia el récord es
de 60 millones de personas con el aforo
y gracias a la ley que se firmó el año
pasado
ahorrando
millones ahorrando 800 dólares en Casos
particulares para los premios esa ley
fue escrita el beneficio expira en 2025
mi petición en algunos de ustedes en
esta audiencia es que por favor
terminemos el trabajo hagamos que estos
ahorros sean permanentes expandamos la
cobertura del medicake
[Aplausos]
miren
el acta de reducción de la inflación es
la inversión más significativa en el
cambio climático en toda la historia
[Aplausos]
el acta de
liderar un mundo con una economía limpia
yo he visitado lugares con una
ocurrencia histórica de lluvias Arizona
Nuevo México todo el camino hasta la
frontera canadiense Más madera sea
quemado la observado desde helicópteros
que el tamaño del estado de Missouri y
creemos todavía que el calentamiento
global es un problema en adición
con las emergencias de recuperación en
Puerto Rico hay bajo estamos
reconstruyendo para el largo plazo Hay
nuevas parrillas de energía para
que se asegura sin pedir estos incendios
forestales vamos a tratar de construir
vidas que eviten las inundaciones
políticas antipolución va a fortalecer
comunidades vamos a construir
muchas estaciones de recarga eléctrica
en todo el país
y esto requerirá decenas de miles de
trabajadores
vamos a ayudar a que familias ahorren
más de mil dólares al año con
extensiones Fiscales a los vehículos
eléctricos
va a haber unos esfuerzos históricos de
conservación para que seamos unos
administradores responsables de nuestra
tierra la crisis climática no se
preocupa si ustedes están en un estado
rojo o azul Es una amenaza existencial Y
tenemos una obligación no con nosotros y
no con nuestros hijos y nietos de
enfrentarlo me enorgullece
cómo Estados Unidos finalmente está
enfrentándose desafío vamos a necesitar
petróleo y gas por un tiempo Pero saben
que miren lo necesitamos es cierto
Pero hay mucho más por hacer tenemos que
terminar el trabajo hemos pagado por
estas inversiones
al hacer
que las corporaciones más poderosas y
más ricas empiecen a pagar su parte esto
acaba de empezar
miren yo soy un capitalista pero hay que
pagar la parte justa creo que muchos de
ustedes en casa muchos de ustedes en
casa están de acuerdo conmigo muchas de
las personas que ustedes conocen
el sistema fiscal no es justo
no es justo
miren
la idea
de que en 2020
55 de las corporaciones más grandes de
Estados Unidos del 8500 y si es en 40
mil millones de dólares en ganancias y
pagarán cero en impuestos federales 0
damas y caballeros esto Simplemente no
es justo pero ahora por la ley que firme
las compañías multimillonarias deben
pagar un mínimo de 15% en impuestos
15 por ciento eso es menos de lo que
paga una enfermera
Déjenme ser bastante Claro Lo dije al
principio bajo mi plan mientras era
presidente nadie ganando menos de 400
mil dólares pagará
un centavo adicional en impuestos ni un
centavo adicional terminemos el trabajo
hay mucho más por hacer
tenemos que recompensar el trabajo no
solamente la riqueza
aprueben mi propuesta para el impuesto
mínimo a los multimillonarios
hay mil multimillonarios en Estados
Unidos son como eran como 600 al inicio
de mi periodo pero ningún
multimillonario debería pagar una menor
tasa de impuestos que un profesor de
escuela o un bombero y hablo en serio
piensen al respecto
Amén miren miren
[Aplausos]
sé que no hay mucho entusiasmo de este
lado pero piensen en esto piensen en
esto
se han dado cuenta que las grandes
petroleras han reportado sus ganancias
el año pasado hicieron 200 mil millones
de dólares en medio de una crisis global
energética creo que eso es absurdo
porque
invirtieron muy poco de ese dinero en
incrementar la producción doméstica
cuando hablé con un par
dijeron que estaban preocupados porque
yo iba a cerrar toda la refinerías y Los
Pozos que Porque habría que invertir yo
dije que vamos a necesitar petróleo por
al menos una década
mucho más de eso también Vamos a
necesitarlo la producción
si hubiera invertido en la producción
para mantener el precio de la gasolina
abajo Bueno en vez de recomprar sus
propias acciones recompensando a sus
presidentes a sus accionistas las
corporaciones tienen que hacerlo
correcto por eso es que propongo que
cuadrupilemos
cuadrupliquemos el impuesto a estas
grandes compañías para que nos
permitamos hacer grandes inversiones
terminemos el trabajo de verdad cerremos
estos vacíos legales para que los ricos
eviten el pago de impuestos en vez de
recortar los impuestos de contribuyentes
adinerados
he querido que tratemos de perseguir el
vacío fiscal de las personas que no son
fiscalmente responsables y que evaden
los impuestos en los últimos años
en los últimos dos años de
administración ha cortado el déficit en
más de uno punto siete
millones de dólares el mayor la mayor
reducción de déficit en la historia de
Estados Unidos bajo la administración
previa el déficit estadounidense aumentó
4 años seguidos por estos déficits
ningún presidente puede agregarle nadie
a la deuda del país
más allá de mi profesor
casi 25% de esta deuda que nos tomamos
200 años en acumular solamente tomó la
presencia de una administración y estos
son los hechos mirenlos miren los
revisenlos
Cómo respondió el congreso a eso a esa
deuda hicieron lo correcto levantaron el
techo de la deuda tres veces para evitar
la crisis ellos pagaron la cuenta de los
Estados Unidos para impedir un desastre
económico en el país Así que hoy le
estoy pidiendo al congreso que siga esta
esta idea complementámonos
para que Estados Unidos y su congreso y
Su autoridad no sea cuestionada algunos
de mis amigos republicanos
querían hacer que bueno la economía
fuera su rehén a no ser que acordara sus
planes
en casa todos deben saber cuáles son
esos panes en vez de ser que los ricos
pagarán su parte algunos republicanos
querían acabar con Medicare no estoy
diciendo que es una mayoría
Déjenme a cualquiera que lo dude
contacte a mi oficina Yo les voy a dar
una copia una copia de la propuesta
eso significa que el congreso no vota
me alegra que lo estén viendo debo
decirle disfruto mucho de la conversión
miren
si el congreso no mantiene los programas
donde están los republicanos van a decir
y no estoy diciendo que es una mayoría
de ustedes ni siquiera estoy diciendo
que sea una cantidad significativa
pero se está haciendo propuesto por
parte de individuos no estoy nombrandolo
educadamente Pero hay unos de ustedes se
lo están proponiendo miren
damas y caballeros
las ideas
hay hay ideas
que no vamos a dejarnos amenazar por
hacer un deporte en la deuda sino
respondemos a esto
[Aplausos]
damas y caballeros
ya que estamos todos en una cuerda
aparente
asegura Hay que sacar a Medicare de
estos libros sí
[Aplausos]
hay unanimidad
por favor
permítale a meditar existir para los
adultos mayores
esta noche lleguemos a un acuerdo
defendamos al adulto mayor creo que
llegamos a ese acuerdo hoy
mostrémosles no vamos a cortar la
seguridad social lo vamos a acabar con
el Medicare
esos beneficios le pertenece al pueblo
estadounidense se lo han ganado sí
alguien intenta quitarles eso y
Aparentemente nadie lo va a hacer Si
alguien lo intenta yo voy a detenerlos
yo lo voy a vetar
y miren no quiero
encerrarlos no quiero sacarlos Ni hoy ni
nunca pero Aparentemente esto no va a
ser un problema el próximo mes cuando
ofrezca mi plan fiscal le preguntaré a
mis amigos republicanos que trascen su
plan también y realmente hablo en serio
nos sentaremos juntos y discutiremos
nuestros planes mutos Unidos
hagamos eso
[Aplausos]
puedo decirlo puedo decirles el plan que
les voy a mostrar va a cortar el déficit
en unos dos billones de dólares y no va
a recortar ninguna parte del mediquero
de la seguridad social vamos a extender
el fondo de mediter al menos dos décadas
tenemos que mantenerlo solventes cierto
no hemos aumentado los impuestos a nadie
que haga menos de 400 mil dólares
vamos a asegurarnos que los ricos y las
grandes corporaciones paguen lo justo
miren miren este es el trato
No Solamente vamos a tomar ventaja del
código fiscal
ni del consumidor estadounidense Este es
mi mensaje para todos ustedes allá yo
los estoy respaldando ya estamos
impidiendo
unas cuantas sorpresa de salud estamos
impidiendo cuentas de mil millones de
dólares al mes en salud protegiendo
los ahorros del adulto mayor
acabando con los hogares de asistencia
que estén haciendo fraude que prescriban
drogas que no se necesitan millos
millones de estadounidenses pueden
ayudar pueden ahorrar miles de dólares
porque finalmente pueden recibir una
ayuda auditiva sin recibir una
prescripción miren
el capitalismo
sin la competencia no es capitalismo es
extorsión
es explotación el año pasado acabé con
ayuda de muchos de ustedes unas
compañías extranjeras que estaban
haciendo que ustedes pagaran mayores
precios por cualquier bien que llegan al
país firmé un acta bipartidista para
recortar costos de envío el 90% de
ayudándole a los granjeros a los
negociantes a los consumidores
estadounidenses terminemos el trabajo
aprobemos
la ley de fortalecimiento económico
bipartidista impidamos que las grandes
plataformas online den productos con una
ventaja injusta
[Aplausos]
mi administración también Está tratando
de acabar con estas estos cargos ocultos
que muchas compañías utilizan para hacer
que paguen de más
vamos a hacer que las aerolíneas les
muestren el precio completo de Los
tiquetes de frente
que les devuelve el dinero si los vuelos
son cancelados o demorados
vamos a tratar de ahorrarle a los
consumidores mil millones de dólares al
año recortando
cosas recurrentes de 30 a 7 dólares por
ejemplo miren
estas cuotas pueden no importarle a los
adinerados pero sí le importa a la gente
de la clase media la gente pobre donde
yo crecí eso suman cientos dólares al
mes hacen que pagar las cuentas sea
difícil que no puedas ir a viajar y yo
se lo Injusto que se siente cuando una
compañía hace un sobrecargo y se sale
con la suya y eso ya no va a pasar hemos
construido una ley para impedir eso que
se llama la acta de prevención de cuotas
injustas
estas cuotas pueden
aumentar las cuentas de hoteles al menos
en 90 dólares y ni siquiera son resorts
Miren la idea de que el internet de que
las compañías de celular puedan
cargarles 200 dólares o más
sin cambiar de proveedores ridículo
podemos impedir estas cuotas de
servicios
en tiquetes de conciertos de eventos
deportivos y que las compañías acaben
con estas cuotas prohibir las aerolíneas
el costo de 50 dólares extra para que se
sienten las familias unidas
es suficiente
las aerolíneas después tienen que dejar
de tratar a los niños como basura los
estadounidenses estamos cansados estamos
cansados de que nos traten mal y crean
que somos tontos
aprueben esta ley
aprueben esta acta para que las
compañías dejen de estafarnos por
demasiado tiempo esto ha pasado los
trabajadores han sido asaltados pero ya
no más
estamos empezando a restaurar la
dignidad del trabajador por ejemplo
debió haber sabido esto pero no lo sabía
hasta hace unos dos años 30 millones de
trabajadores tuvieron que firmar unas
acuerdos de no Competencia por los
trabajos que toman 30 millones un cajero
en un sitio de hamburguesas no puede
caminar al otro lado del pueblo y tomar
el mismo trabajo en un sitio y ganarse
un poco de plata más hay que cambiarlo
lo cambiamos porque lo expusimos eso era
parte del trato miren miren lo revisen
los señores pero esto ya no es así
estamos impidiendo esos acuerdos para
que la gente tenga que competir las
compañías tiene que competir por los
trabajadores y pagarles lo que valen
[Aplausos]
y debo decirles
esto es una respuesta que une a la
derecha con la izquierda
Me agotaron las compañías que impiden
que los trabajadores se organicen por
favor aprenden esta acta los
trabajadores tienen derecho a formar un
sindicato
garanticemos a todos los trabajadores un
salario básico con el que pueda vivir
que los padres puedan criar a sus
familias Que tengan días de descanso
suficiente dinero un sistema de Cuidado
infantil accesible
eso va a permitir que millones de
personas sigan trabajando
podemos restaurar también el crédito
fiscal a los niños para darle decenas de
miles de padres un momento de descanso y
sacar a los niños de la pobreza Por
cierto mientras Hacemos todas estas
cosas tenemos que incrementar la
productividad y lo hacemos incrementamos
el crecimiento económico terminemos este
trabajo ya estamos hagamos que más
familias tengan acceso a unas casas a
que los adultos también puedan tener un
hogar a que tengan cuidado démosle
cuidado démosle espacio a las familias
para que cuiden a sus seres queridos que
están enfermas aprueba mi plan para que
los adultos mayores y las personas con
discapacidades tengan los servicios que
necesitan y el respaldo
al trabajador para que ellos sigan
haciendo el trabajo que deben hacer
estos planes pueden ser pagados los
podemos pagar restaura la dignidad del
trabajo significa hacer que la educación
sea accesible a la clase media cuando
hablamos de la educación pública doce
años de Educación universal
cuando lo probamos nos volvimos en la
nación más educada y mejor pagada del
mundo el resto del mundo ya se puso al
tanto Jill mi esposa que es profesora de
tiempo completo tiene una expresión
espero
tenerla bien cada nación que se eduque
mejor que nosotros va a competir y nos
va a ganar
damas y caballeros todos sabemos que 12
años de Educación no son suficiente para
ganar la competencia económica del Siglo
[Aplausos]
queremos tener la fuerza laboral más
educada tenemos que terminar este
trabajo
[Aplausos]
al darle acceso a preescolar a los niños
los estudios muestran que los niños que
van a preescolar
tiene una una posibilidad de 50 por
ciento más determinar la escuela y
llegar a la universidad sin importar sus
antecedentes démosle Un aumento a los
profesores de las escuelas también
[Aplausos]
estamos logrando Progreso
al reducir la deuda escolar incrementar
las becas pel para las familias de clase
media terminemos este trabajo conectemos
a los estudiantes con las carreras
académicas desde la escuela démosle
acceso a los niños a dos años de
Educación Universitaria pavimentamos el
camino a una educación de cuatro años
más ofrezcamosle a los estadounidenses
un camino a la buena educación sea que
vayan o no a la universidad
damas y caballeros
en medio de esta crisis por el covid
cuando las escuelas estaban siendo
cerradas
y estamos clausurándolo todo
debemos reconocer lo lejos que llegamos
en la lucha en contra de la pandemia en
sí misma Aunque el virus no se haya ido
Gracias a la resiliencia del pueblo
estadounidense y el Ingenio de la
medicina hemos roto el control del covid
el covid está disminuyendo al menos del
10% hemos salvado millones de vidas y
hemos abierto la economía de nuestro
país pronto terminaremos la emergencia
pública la emergencia de salud pública
Así es como se llama
pero recordaremos los dolores y la carga
que nos dejó que no nos va a abandonar
nunca más de un millón de
estadounidenses Perdieron su vida por el
covid más de un millón hay familias que
siguen en luto hay niños que siguen que
son huérfanos
hay sillas vacías en las mesas de
nuestras cenas que nos recuerdan quien
solía sentarse allí
mientras lo recordamos seguimos
vigilantes debemos monitorear a docenas
de variantes y tratarlas con nuevas
vacunas el congreso necesita patrocinar
estos esfuerzos y mantener Estados
Unidos
con seguridad
a medida que salimos de esta crisis más
fuerte tenemos que duplicar nuestros
esfuerzos de perseguir a los criminales
que quitaron dinero a clínicas a los
esfuerzos médicos
antes de llegar al cargo recordarán
ustedes durante esta campaña del mayor
tema fue el tema de la inspección
general que protegía los dólares de los
contribuyentes esas personas fueron
expulsadas muchos dijeron que no los
necesitaríamos y el fraude creció el año
pasado les dije que los observadores
estaban de vuelta y desde entonces hemos
recuperado miles de millones de dólares
de los contribuyentes ahora triplicamos
la fuerza en contra de estos criminales
hemos duplicado hemos duplicado los
estatutos y trataremos de acabar
el robo de identidad que termina con el
robo de miles de millones de dólares del
pueblo estadounidense
los datos muestran que por cada dólar
que ponemos en la lucha contra el fraude
recuperamos 10 dólares o más por cada
dólar y esto es importante miren dejó
fuertes cicatrices
como el aumento del crimen violento en
2020 el primer año de la pandemia
tenemos una obligación para asegurarnos
de que todas las personas estén a salvo
la seguridad pública depende de la
confianza todos lo sabemos pero esa
confianza es violada frecuentemente
junto con nosotros está en los padres de
nicholes bienvenidos
[Aplausos]
tuvieron que enterrar a tairi la semana
pasada
[Aplausos]
con muchos de ustedes ya saben
personalmente no hay palabras para
describir el dolor de perder a un hijo
pero imagínenselo
imagínense perder a ese hijo A manos de
la ley
imaginen
tener que pensar si su hijo o hija
regresó de la calle de jugar en un
parque o de estar manejando muchos de
nosotros acá nunca hemos tenido que
tener esa charla esa discusión
que los padres De tez morena han tenido
que darle a sus hijos yo nunca tuve que
decirle nada de eso a mis hijos nunca
tuve que decirles de que si un policía
los detenía tenían que aprender las
luces y separar las manos no alcanzar a
su licencia mantener sus manos en el
volante
imagínense tener que pensar en algo así
Cada vez
que su hijo entra un auto
eso fue lo que me dijo la tal vez Cuando
hable con ella cuando le pregunté cómo
encuentro el coraje de seguir hablando
con la fe que tienen Dios Ella dice
Bueno mi hijo era una alma hermosa y
algo bueno tiene que salir de todo esto
imagínense el coraje que requiere hacer
algo así depende de nosotros de todos
nosotros Todos queremos lo mismo
un vecindario libre de violencia
una fuerza policial con la confianza de
la comunidad
Ellos tienen el derecho a regresar a
casa el resto de personas también
nuestros hijos
tienen el derecho de regresar con
seguridad a casa necesitamos una
protección igualitaria bajo la ley ese
es un trato que tenemos aquí el uno con
el otro en Estados Unidos
todos sabemos
que los oficiales de policía arriesgan
su vida todos los días todos sabemos que
les pedimos que hagan demasiado
consejeros trabajadores sociales
psicólogos
médicos de sobredosis muchas cosas y les
pedimos demasiado es totalmente cierto y
sé que muchos policías y sus familias
son personas decentes y honorables como
la gran mayoría ellos arriesgan
y ellos se arriesgan sus vidas cada vez
que se ponen esa placa
pero lo que le pasó a Memphis pasa
demasiado frecuentemente y tenemos que
hacerlo mejor darle a la policía el
entrenamiento real que necesita
tener que presentarles mejores
estándares ayudarles a cumplir éxito a
cumplir con éxito su tarea de la
seguridad necesitamos
profesionales que estén enfrentando el
abuso de sustancias recursos para acabar
con el crimen violento intervenciones
comunitarias más inversión en educación
en hogares en entrenamiento
todo eso puede llorar a prevenir la
violencia en primer lugar
cuando los oficiales de policía los
departamentos de policía violan la
confianza pública deben ser hechos
responsables
con el respaldo
de las familias de las víctimas
de las fuerzas policiales yo firmo una
orden ejecutiva donde todos los
oficiales federales donde se ve veta el
uso de técnicas de ahogamiento y otros
elementos de esta acta de Florida
complementámonos con hacer que las
palabras de la mamá de tairi sean
correctas algo bueno tiene que salir de
esto algo bueno
todos nosotros
[Aplausos]
damas y caballeros es difícil pero es
simple todos nosotros en esta cámara
tenemos que ponernos a la altura de este
momento no podemos mirar a otro lado
hagamos lo que sabemos que tenemos que
hacer en el corazón lo que necesitamos
hacer
reunámonos a terminar el trabajo sobre
la reforma policial hagamos algo hagamos
algo
eso fue lo que cada padre que ha perdido
sus hijos ante la violencia Armada me
pidió que hiciera que dijera hagan algo
y gracias a Dios que lo hicimos
aprobamos la ley más avasalladora en
seguridad sobre armas en las últimas
décadas esto incluye cosas como
que la mayoría de propietarios de armas
responsables
reciba respaldo y que haya revisiones de
antecedentes para menores de 21 años hay
que revisar las banderas rojas las
advertencias para que no caigan en manos
de las personas equivocadas y sabemos
que todo hay mucho por hacer hoy está
con nosotros Brandon
Un héroe de 26 años
[Música]
puso sus sueños universitarios
tuvo que ponerlos a esperar mientras su
madre estaba muriendo por cáncer Brandon
ahora a trabajar un estudio y respaldan
sus abuelos hace dos semanas durante la
celebración del año lunar
escucharon cerrar la puerta del estudio
de un hombre apuntar un arma
semiautomática hacia él pensó que iba a
morir
Pero pensó en las personas que estaban
ahí adentro y en ese instante encontró
el coraje de actuar
y empujar al hombre armado que ya había
matado 11 personas en otro estudio 11
personas ya las había matado él salvó
vidas
es momento de que hagamos lo mismo
metemos las armas de asalto ahora
metemos las ahora de una vez por todas
lideré la lucha para lograrlo en 1994
en 10 años que esa ley estuvo en acción
decrecieron los tiroteos pero después de
que se derogó se triplicaron metemos las
armas de asalto también reunamos sobre
el tema migratorio Hagamos una
iniciativa hoy partidista al respecto de
nuevo
sabemos ahora tenemos un número récord
de personal trabajando en la frontera
hemos arrestado
cientos de traficantes humanos hemos
incautado toneladas de fentanilo en los
últimos meses hemos lanzado un nuevo
plan fronterizo recientemente el mes
pasado una ley mercantil de migración de
Cuba Nicaragua Haití Venezuela
disminuido el paso de personas por 97%
pero el congreso tiene que seguir
actuando si no aprobamos mi reforma
migratoria integral al menos aprobemos
el plan para darle el equipo a los
oficiales fronterizos para que hagan
bien su trabajo
[Aplausos]
un camino a la ciudadanía también para
los dreamers
aquellos que están en estatus temporal
trabajadores en granjas trabajadores
esenciales
nuestro deber es proteger los derechos
de todos las libertades de todos el
congreso debe restaurar el derecho
el congreso debe restaurar el derecho
que fue arrebatado en Rose versus
[Aplausos]
tenemos que hacerlo la vicepresidente y
yo estamos haciendo todo lo posible
para
que haya acceso a la salud reproductiva
y salvaguardas
al menos dos estados están actuando con
leyes restrictivas en abortos si el
congreso aprueba un acta nacional
receptiva Yo la voy a vetar pero también
tenemos que aprobar
También tenemos que aprobar el acta
bipartidista de igualdad para
asegurarnos que la comunidad
Especialmente los jóvenes transgénero
puedan vivir con seguridad y con
dignidad nuestra fortaleza
[Aplausos]
nuestra fortaleza no solamente es el
ejemplo de nuestro poder sino El poder
del ejemplo que damos
recordemos que el mundo está
observándonos
hable hace un año en esta cámara solo
días después de que el presidente Putin
desatar esos ataques sobre Ucrania
asalto asesino grandes imágenes
Terribles de sufrimiento y de dolor que
solamente recordamos de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial la invasión de Putin ha
sido una prueba para nuestra era una
prueba para Estados Unidos y una prueba
para el mundo
para los que defendemos los principios
más básicos para los que defendimos la
soberanía
por el derecho de las personas de vivir
libre de la tiranía por la defensa de la
Democracia
porque esta defensa es importante
mantiene la paz
e impide la presencia de agresores en
contra de nuestra prosperidad
un año después sabemos la respuesta
Y sí lo logramos lo hicimos
juntos
Hicimos lo que Estados Unidos siempre
hace su mejor momento liderar unimos a
la otan
creamos una coalición global defendimos
si nos mantuvimos firmes ante la
agresión de Putin
respaldamos a Ucrania y aquí está el
embasador de Ucrania que no solamente
representa a su nación sino el coraje de
su pueblo embajador los trabajadores
saca también
estamos Unidos Aquí en el respaldo de su
país todos tenemos que mirarlo usted
y darle las gracias
[Aplausos]
el mundo está de su lado
por el tiempo que sea necesario
[Aplausos]
nuestras naciones están trabajando por
mayor dignidad mayor libertad y mayor
Paz No solamente en Europa sino en todas
partes antes de venir al cargo se
trataba de cómo la República Popular de
China estaba aumentando su poder y
Estados Unidos estaba fracasando en ello
pero ya no es así
dejamos claro
lo he dejado Claro en mis conversaciones
personas con el presidente Chiki
buscamos competencia no conflicto pero
no me voy a disculpar jamás de invertir
de hacer Estados Unidos más fuerte
invertir en Innovación estadounidense
Esto va a definir el futuro que china
espera dominar
invertir en nuestras alianzas en el
trabajo con nuestros aliados para
proteger las tecnologías avanzadas para
que no sean usadas en contra nuestra
modernizar nuestros ejércitos para
salvaguardar la estabilidad y bueno
impedir la agresión y Hoy estamos en la
posición más fuerte que hemos estado en
décadas para combatir cochino cualquier
otra persona en cualquier otro país en
el mundo
estamos comprometidos
[Aplausos]
estoy comprometido trabajar con china
donde podamos avanzar en los intereses
estadounidenses y el mundo pero no
cometamos aquí errores
como dejamos claro la semana pasada si
china
amenazan nuestra soberanía actuariamos
proteger en nuestro país y ya lo hemos
hecho
[Aplausos]
miren
seamos claros
estamos en una competencia para unirnos
estamos enfrentando grandes desafíos en
todo el mundo pero los últimos dos años
las democracias se han hecho más fuertes
no más débiles las autocracias se han
hecho más débiles y no más fuertes
nombres ni un líder mundial
que cambiaría lugares con nombre a uno
Estados Unidos está reuniendo al mundo
para enfrentar estos desafíos desde el
clima hasta la salud mundial hasta la
seguridad alimentaria hasta el
terrorismo hasta la agresión territorial
los aliados están aumentando sus
esfuerzos están gastando más miren
los puentes que estamos haciendo entre
los socios en el Pacífico y el Atlántico
y aquellos que aquellos que están
apostando en contra de Estados Unidos se
están dando cuenta de lo equivocados que
está Nunca es un buen momento para
apostar en contra de Estados Unidos
miren
[Aplausos]
cuando llegué al cargo
el bipartidismo era imposible pero Nunca
creí que fuera así por eso fue que hace
un año ofrecí una agenda de unidad a la
nación y logramos un gran Progreso
juntos aprobamos una ley que facilitara
a los doctores recetar drogas para
combatir la adicción a los opiáceos
hicimos
grandes inversiones En Salud Mental
lanzamos
grandes investigaciones para la lucha
contra él Alzheimer la diabetes y muchas
enfermedades más aprobamos el acto Lee
Robinson
nombrado
por
nombrado por un veterano de guerra que
estuvo el año pasado acá que fue víctima
de los sumos tóxicos
[Aplausos]
Yo entiendo algo de esto somos tóxicos
Pero hay mucho mucho más por hacer y
podemos hacerlo juntos junto con
nosotros aquí Hoy está un padre llamado
dog de Newton
[Música]
él escribió allí mi esposa y a mí una
carta
sobre su hija
una risa contagiosa la mejor amiga de su
hermana
compartió una historia muy familiar para
muchos estadounidenses para muchos de
ustedes en la audiencia
cornia descubrió las píldoras en la
escuela entró a la adicción en un
espiral finalmente murió de una
sobredosis de fentanilo y tenía sólo 20
años
los últimos ocho años de su vida fueron
como que no hubiera un dolor peor según
su padre doc si las familias convierten
el dolor en propósito podríamos acabar
con este estigma y cambiar las leyes
nos dijo que quiere empezar un viaje a
la recuperación de Estados Unidos
nosotros estamos con usted el fentanilo
está matando a más de 70.000
estadounidenses al año
así es
lanzamos una incremento
en el combate contra el fentanilo
utilicemos drogas de inspección para las
drogas detengamos el ingreso de estas
drogas en las fronteras tenemos que
aumentar nuestros esfuerzos
trabajemos con organizaciones como FedEx
para inspeccionar mejor los paquetes por
drogas
tenemos que acabar con el tráfico de
segundo más tenemos que ayudar más en
temas de Salud Mental especialmente para
los niños millones de jóvenes luchan
contra el bullying la violencia el
trauma tenemos que darles mayor acceso a
la Salud Mental en las escuelas
tenemos que hacer que las compañías de
redes sociales sean responsables por los
experimentos que hacen en nuestros hijos
por beneficio económico momento de pasar
y aprobar Lady artista para detener a
las grandes compañías tecnológicas
[Música]
de recolectar datos sobre nosotros sobre
nuestros niños
que dejen de darle
publicidad a los niños poner límites en
los datos que se recolectan de todos
nosotros En tercer lugar
hay que hacer más para sostener la
obligación Sagrada
de cuidarlos a nuestros veteranos cuando
regresen a casa entrenamiento laboral
ubicación laboral para ellos y para sus
esposas a medida que regresan a la vida
civil ayudar a los veteranos con su
renta porque nadie debe estar sin hogar
en Estados Unidos mucho menos alguien
que sirvió al país
[Aplausos]
está aquí es del departamento de asuntos
de veteranos tuvimos una discusión muy
seria cuando le pedí que asumiera el
cargo y me alegra que lo hubiera hecho
Estamos perdiendo al menos 25 veteranos
al día al suicidio horas son 17
esta carga silenciosa del suicidio bueno
son 17 que todavía lo están haciendo al
día mucha más que todas las personas que
mueren en cada guerra
damas y caballeros
la oficina de trance está haciendo todo
lo posible incluyendo expandir el
monitoreo de Salud Mental
un programas para reclutar a veteranos
para ayudarle otros veteranos a entender
lo que está pasando la ayuda que
necesitan y tenemos que hacer más en
cuarto lugar
el año pasado jilly y yo fuimos a
empezar una tradición llamada mucho es
algo que supe
cortar las tasas de muertes por cáncer
al menos en 15% aquí a los últimos los
próximos 25 años el cáncer tiene que ser
convencido de una sentencia de muerte
una enfermedad tratable hay que darle
respaldo a las familias eso es personal
para muchos de nosotros muchos en esta
audiencia incluso
junto a nosotros están Morrison
una Irlandés y una hija de migrantes
panameños ellos se enamoraron en Nueva
York y se casaron en la capilla en la
que yo nos casamos allá son espíritus
muy amables se nos escribe una carta
sobre su hija pequeña haba eiba la vi
justo antes de venir
tenía solo un año de edad cuando se le
diagnosticó un cáncer en los riñones
después de 26 transfusiones 11 rondas de
radiación ocho rondas de quimioterapia
un riñón removido se le dio 15% de una
de tasa de supervivencia describió la
carta en el peor momento dijo que si ya
se va Yo no me imagino quedándome muchos
de ustedes también ha pasado por esa
situación
entendimos eso como muchos de ustedes él
leyó el libro de Jill escribiendo la
situación de cáncer de nuestra familia
como trato de quitar los momentos de
alegría
por ejemplo
para él la emoción venía de la sonrisa
de su hija significaba todo para él
nunca abandonó la esperanza
Ellos nunca abandonó la esperanza ella
cumple cuatro años la otra semana de
hecho
acaban de saber que iba
estaba venciendo el cáncer y está en
camino
a estar curado está viendo esta
conferencias de la casa blanca si no se
ha dormido a uno Esta es una de las
vidas que podemos salvar
por las vías que podemos salvar y por
las vías que hemos perdido
dejemos que este sea un verdadero
momento estadounidense que reúna al país
y al mundo que demuestre que todavía
podemos hacer cosas importantes hace 20
años bajo el liderazgo del presidente el
bus
él asumió un esfuerzo de partidista para
transformar la lucha en contra del sí
del VIH esto ha sido un gran éxito
él pensó en grande
él actuó
yo creo que podemos hacer lo mismo con
el cáncer
acabamos con el cáncer como lo conocemos
curemos algunos cánceres de una vez por
todas
damas y caballeros hay una razón por la
cual hemos podido hacer todas estas
cosas
nuestra democracia en sí misma es lo más
fundamental de todo con la democracia
todo es posible sin la democracia nada
es posible los últimos años nuestra
democracia ha sido amenazada y atacada
se ha puesto en riesgo
se ha puesto a prueba en esta misma
habitación el 6 de enero y hace unos
cuantos meses
una gran mentira
que desató violencia política bueno en
el hogar de la líder de la cámara
representantes utilizando el mismo
lenguaje de los insurreccionistas
el 6 de enero
aquí en esta cámara hay un hombre que
tiene la cicatrices de ese ataque brutal
pero que es tan fuerte y resiliente como
se puede mi amigo Paul pelosi Paul ponte
de pie
[Aplausos]
fue un acto muy odioso que no debía
haber ocurrido
todos Debemos hablar no hay lugar para
la violencia política en Estados Unidos
tenemos que proteger el derecho a votar
no suprimirlo
los resultados de las elecciones
subvertir el mundo tenemos que mantener
el estado de derecho restaurar la
confianza de las instituciones y la
democracia tenemos que darle al odio el
extremismo
no podemos darle al odio el este mismo
un lugar seguro
la democracia
[Aplausos]
no debe ser un esfuerzo partidista es un
esfuerzo estadounidense
cada generación de estadounidense debe
enfrentar un momento donde se les ha
pedido que protejan la democracia
este es nuestro momento compañeros
estadounidenses nos reunimos en un punto
de inflexión uno de esos momentos que
solamente algunas generaciones se
enfrentan con la dirección que ahora
tomemos
Esto va a decir el curso de esta nación
de aquí a décadas por venir
no somos solamente observadores no
somos vulnerables nada más está en el
poder nuestro somos nosotros el pueblo
estamos enfrentando la prueba de nuestra
era tenemos que ser la nación que
siempre ha sido en el mejor momento
optimista esperanzada que mira el futuro
una nación
que acepta la luz sobre la oscuridad la
esperanza sobre el miedo La estabilidad
sobre el caos tenemos que vernos no como
enemigos sino como compañeros
estadounidenses como gente buena la
única nación en el mundo construida bajo
un ideal la única
[Aplausos]
otras naciones
son definidas por la geografía por su
etnicidad Pero somos la única nación que
parte de una idea
que todos nosotros cada uno de nosotros
es creado igual a la imagen de Dios
una nación que se ha convertido en un
faro para el mundo una nación
en una nueva era de posibilidades He
venido
a cumplir mi obligación constitucional
de reportar el estado de la unión y aquí
está mi reporte
ya que el alma de la nación es fuerte ya
que la columna vertebral de esta nación
es fuerte de que el pueblo de esta
nación es fuerte el estado de la unión
es fuerte
[Aplausos]
no soy nuevo
estoy aquí frente ustedes habiendo
servido tanto como el que más ha servido
nunca he sentido mayor optimismo sobre
nuestro futuro sobre el futuro de
Estados Unidos solamente tenemos que
recordar Quiénes somos somos los Estados
Unidos de América no hay nada nada más
allá de nuestras capacidades y lo
hacemos todos juntos Dios los bendiga a
todos Dios proteja a nuestras tropas
gracias
[Aplausos]